in dieser woche hat das electric college
also das us wahlleute gremium joe biden
zum präsidenten gewählt und jetzt raten
sie doch mal wer trotzdem nicht gehen
will der donny ja der denkt gar nicht
daran seine niederlage endlich
einzugestehen
über 60 gerichte sagen es gibt keine
beweise für wahlbetrug sein eigen
inzwischen zurückgetretene
justizminister sagt das alles egal
der historienfilm obama vor erstens doch
zweitens du hast keine 75 millionen
geholt sondern 74,2 drittens ein
gewisser herr beiden bekamen 81
millionen das sind rund sieben millionen
mehr inhalt
deswegen hat beiden gewonnen zumindest
in dieser realität und trotzdem ostroms
armes team weiter nach beweisen suchen
die nicht da sind zum beispiel hier in
wisconsin 3 millionen dollar zahlt er
sein wahlkampfteam hierfür eine
neuauszählung der stimmen und das
ergebnis joe biden gewannen noch 87
stimmen hinzu aha drei millionen dollar
für 87 beiden stimmen also wurden doch
stimmen gekauft nur halt von trump und
für beiden ja wenn man so bankrottes
wieder donald dann kommt darauf an ihm
er laut new york times hat er ja 421
millionen dollar schulden
jede wette ich schwöre für alles andere
wird er sich am ende ziemlich sicher
begnadigen aber die schulden die bleiben
in wirklichkeit geht es dem man ja nur
noch um eins seiner anhänger sollen joe
biden niemals für einen legitimen
präsidenten halten und dass die
demokratie dabei schweren schaden nimmt
ist dem psychopathen natürlich völlig
wimpel sogar trump chef also putin hat
jetzt beiden gratuliert nur sein anwalt
giuliani der kämpft unermüdlich weiter
alles völlig haltlos trotzdem redet sich
juliane in rage
er fängt so stark an zu schwitzen dass
ihm die haut tönung über die wangen
rennt rudy giuliani nebenbei auch
sprecher der bewegung black herr matters
aber jetzt wird ja alles gut oder muss
doch mit joe biden care-team normalität
zurück
die amerikaner kümmern sich und wir
deutschen dürfen uns ohne allzu viel für
rüstung auszugeben weiter als die guten
fühlen
das können wir einfach am besten ach da
fällt mir ein wie geht's zu beiden
eigentlich joe biden der gewählte us
präsident hat sich beim spiel mit seinem
schäferhund den rechten knöchel
verstaucht und sich mehrere haares
frakturen im fuß zugezogen mehrere
wochen lang muss er nun einen
orthopädischen stützt stiefel tragen
oh gott ein deutscher schäferhund bricht
joe biden den fuß na toll direkt der
nächste rückschlag für die
deutsch-amerikanischen beziehungen
die heute-show verleiht den vollpfosten
2020 mal nicht an donald trump der
kriegt von uns gar nichts mehr
der pfosten geht hoch verdient an seine
partei an die republikaner für absurd
langes ausharren quasi im rektum des
präsidenten gibt es von uns dieses
besonders geschmacklos gestaltete
artefakt herzlichen glückwunsch
ich bin übrigens total gespannt was
champions macht es heißt ja er gründet
einen eigenen tv-sender ihr erster
trailer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
ein leica last ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da